hey there and welcome to inside the
Oscars I'm Rachel Smith and today we're
gonna take you inside the ultimate
Oscars after-party here's your
invitation to go inside the Governor's
Ball
well the Governor's Ball is the official
Academy ball hosted by the governors of
the Academy
it's a celebration at the end of the
ostrich's the show is over and and
everybody comes up to the ballroom and
it's a huge cocktail party it's 20 feet
away from the theater so it's an
extension of the actual Oscar telecast
the people who win the people don't win
the or are hungry and they all are
coming to the Governor's Ball for dinner
when those doors open and the first
guests walk in you want their eyes to
pop open there you want them to see
something special it's unconventional
ball not a sit-down dinner because no
one wants to sit down
it is also dinner for 1500 people there
are you know celebrities everywhere and
Oscars everywhere and it is the place to
be after the Oscars
everybody's automotive serf small
moments rather than longer moments so we
love that we have small bites Wolfgang
Puck's foods tray passed immediately
instead of having one big plate or two
big plates one after one be soft 1012
courses so you can have different kinds
of salads pastas risottos and main
courses and desserts and then naturally
we always give people the gold covered
the chocolate Oscar to take home now so
when they come to the Governor's Ball
everybody's a winner everybody gets an
Oscar it's much more open than people
can mingle and mix it and walk around
and there is entertainment we've had
Tony Bennett entertain us at the ball
and this year are very happy we can tell
you John Legend is of course the
engraving station the actual winners can
go to the engraving station and leave
that night with their Oscar and their
name and the title this way you win your
Oscar you haven't engraved and you take
it home you never have to let go of it
as yours
and it really is very what we want
people to have is having a great party
have great food but also have fun
it shouldn't be a formal starchy you
know event this is like bug you know the
end of the cycle the king of the King
awards that this is it so we were the
create environment that or them kick off
of here if you love movies and you love
the industry you can't help but enjoy
yourself to see more of what's planned
for this year's governors bomb go to
Oscar calm